hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine lieben
zuschauer zu einem neuen quiz auf meinem
kanal und zwar spielen wir heute
gemeinsam die app ihr wilder ein
youtuber stellt das ganze irgendwie
epischer da ist es ist aber gut freunde
hier sieht auf jeden fall hier rechts
neben mir schon die app eingeblendet das
heißt wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf
play ich habe schon fünf runden gespielt
das heißt winzeln level 6 und
es gehe ich mal ein also das ist auf
jeden fall richtig ein wir machen direkt
weiter das jetzt sarrazin mit dem war
ich letzthin auf ein paar locker will
verordnung woche also sei es aber auch
wichtig ihm der nächste youtuber hier
ist ich habe keine ahnung alter
allerdings haben wir dafür ja hier joker
das heißt kann ja einfach mal zeige
einen richtigen buchstaben auswählen für
60 coins und
das bringt mich überhaupt nicht weiter
haben ich könnte mir mal noch ein
buchstaben
das hilft mir auch noch nicht weiter und
ich könnte mir auch noch einen
buchstaben
irgendwas mit sammer gucke ich einfach
keinen youtube oder warum kenne ich die
alle nicht also ich habe ehrlich gesagt
auch keine ahnung wer er hier ist ich
klicke auf den anderen joker da kann man
nämlich für 25 coins buchstaben
rausschmeißen
das heißt sie schmeißt jetzt hier
einfach mal vier buchstaben raus und
nein
ich habe absolut keine ahnung ich möchte
mit kein youtube in keiner form
verletzen oder so dass ich sie nicht
kenne
das ist auf jeden fall rieso aber ich
kann mich einfach nicht so gut aus dem
deutschsprachigen youtube raum ich
glaube dass hier ist marc hensel on habe
ich
banker die wollen doch flachsen oder ich
können wir noch den zweiten buchstaben
das ist ein uhr am ende also gp blut fcr
ich habe keine ahnung warum klappt
überhaupt für mich von ihr buch da mache
ich drei vorgegeben dass jetzt der
nächste youtube ich würde sagen das ist
er kam von resch kaka aber irgendwie hat
der dinge
deswegen hier vier buchstaben also die
kmu sie vielleicht nie auch nicht ich
kann dieses video nicht hochladen alter
ich bin ja komplett beschlossen das
stimmt
ach so du das siehst sorry den kanal
hier kenne ich auf jeden fall dass
mileys welt die haben ja auch irgendwie
fast eine million abonnenten und haben
auch relativ lang dann kommt man
dementsprechend auch er darauf dass hier
noch verarschen den buchstaben nach zu
urteilen kann man auf jeden fall dragon
hier raus machen aber weiter
dragon pap ich war ich habe wieder
absolut keine ahnung
ok dragon cup ich kann dir den channel
auch nicht aber es ist trocken
ich glaube ich bin nicht der einzige dem
es so geht
ich spiele selber täglich fifa aber ich
gucke mir halt überhaupt keine videos
davon auf youtube an
ich würde irgendwas sagen mit ich habe
keine ahnung ich lass mir wieder
buchstaben geben und zwar diesmal drei
stück das ding ist ich glaube das okay
ich hätte nie gedacht dass es mit zehn
fängt mein gott was haben die denn alle
für krasse namen ich würde sagen dass
wir noch zwei youtuber machen und
versuchen so level 20 zu kommen
das hier ist rob babbel den kenne ich
auf jeden fall so der es richtig unter
nächste youtuber das ist
[Musik]
ich habe ja noch 228 kreuz das heißt ich
lasse mir wieder drei buchstaben geben
und schmeißt jetzt auch noch mal einen
buchstaben raus das heißt ich habe keine
ahnung ich gebs auf andere städte über
die summe das heutige video jetzt auch
beenden meiner liebe freunde ich habe
vor einigen jahren schon mal ein video
hochgeladen in dem ich vier bilder einem
youtuber gespielt habe und da lief es
auf jeden fall deutlich besser wenn ich
das heutige video dennoch gefallen da
würde ich mich sehr darüber einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freund schreiben wir uns in die
kommentare während dieser youtuber hier
ist soll müsse
[Musik]